Britain has a long tradition of fringe
parties but mainstream politicians who
dismissed you kept as eccentrics are now
seriously worried voters in a local
by-election seem set to hand victory to
Nigel Farage and his anti-european UK
Independence Party Farraj here on the
right already has this MP douglas
Carswell he defected from the ruling
Conservative Party that triggered a
local election back in October which he
won you Kip wants to see Britain leave
the European Union and imposed tough
restrictions on immigration and migrants
today's vote could put a second toid
effector mark reckless into Parliament
for you Kip you kept her the only party
who have a non-discriminatory system
which we want to apply equally to people
from outside the EU where the
Commonwealth stay from Africa off in the
Caribbean they should be treated fairly
and equally rather than having a system
which discriminates in favour of
Europeans the main political parties are
showing the strain not only are they
hemorrhaging voter support they're also
talking tough on you kept themes i said
i want for action not just talking
immigration i believe people should come
here to work and contribute and we need
to take more action on people being able
to claim benefits you Kip has already
succeeded in pushing the established
parties into more populist positions on
immigration and conservative Prime
Minister David Cameron has promised a
referendum on whether Britain should
leave the European Union in the country
at large the center-right conservative
and center left Labour Party's have
rarely been less popular some predict
you Kip could even break their grip on
British politics altogether a win here
in rochester and strood could be an
important step along the way Farraj is
focusing on further reducing their
dominance he's hoping good result today
will give his party enough momentum to
create an upset in Mays general election
just half a year away
I don't think anyone knows and that's
the point about today that if you get
wind today in what is are 270 first
target scene I think all bets are off in
terms of predicting what could happen
next made this will open up British
politics in a remarkable way whether
fears of migrants whomping Britain are
actually justified is not even part of
the discussion voters today seem to be
ready to follow their gut feelings this
is raising speculation that others
across the country could do the same in
next year's general election